KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE,
JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS AND
GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
ANOTHER MEETING ON SCHOOL SAFETY
AT THE WHITE HOUSE TODAY AS
CONGRESS MOVES TO TAKE ACTION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WINNING SOME
RARE PRAISE FROM THE SENATE TOP
DEMOCRAT FOR SIGNALING HE IS
OPEN TO CHANGING OUR NATION'S
GUN LAWS.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE CREDIT
WHERE CREDIT IS DUE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE A LOT OF
THINGS RIGHT YESTERDAY.
HE SEEMED TO STRONGLY ENDORSE
BACKGROUND CHECKS, TO ENSURE
PEOPLE WHO SHOULDN'T HAVE A GUN
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO ONE.
IMPORTANTLY, THE PRESIDENT
ACKNOWLEDGED TAKING MEANINGFUL
STEPS TO IMPROVE GUN SAFETY IS
GOING TO REQUIRE BUCKING THE
NRA.
THE MEETING AND THE PRESIDENT'S
COMMENTS WERE AN ENCOURAGING
STEP.
>> Dana: >> Dana: SCHUMER
>> Dana: >> Dana: SCHUMEU
>> Dana: >> Dana: SCHUMEV
>> Dana: >> Dana: SCHUMEI
>> Dana: >> Dana: SCHUMEE
>> Dana: >> Dana: SCHUMED
>> Dana: >> Dana: SCHUMEA
THREE-PART GUN CONTROL PLAN FROM
DEMOCRATS TODAY.
HE INSISTS A BAN ON ASSAULT
WEAPONS BE PART OF THE DEBATE.
MARCO RUBIO PITCHED HIS OWN
PROPOSALS, INCLUDING
CONFISCATING FROM GUNS FROM
THOSE WHO POSE A TRUST.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SUPPORTS THAT
IDEA, BUT NOT THE NRA.
>> I LIKE TAKING THE GUNS EARLY.
IN THIS CRAZY MAN'S CASE THAT
TOOK PLACE IN FLORIDA, HE HAD A
LOT OF THINGS, THEY SAW
EVERYTHING.
TO GO TO COURT WOULD'VE TAKEN A
LONG TIME.
TAKE THE GUNS FIRST.
DO THE DUE PROCESS SECOND.
>> THERE IS A WAY YOU CAN
PROTECT DUE PROCESS AND PROTECT
THE RIGHTS OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WHILE ALSO HARDENING
THE SCHOOLS AND KEEPING KIDS
SAFE.
>> Dana: GREGG,
SENATOR SCHUMER SAID THEY WILL
INTRODUCE A BILL THAT THEY
EXPECT IT'S POSSIBLE -- I'M
SORRY IT JUST CAME IN.
IT COULD PASS SCHUMER'S PROPOSAL
WITH MOSTLY DEMOCRATIC SUPPORT
AND A FEW REPUBLICANS ENCOURAGED
BY PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Greg: THAT BILL ISN'T GOING
TO HAPPEN.
I CAN SAFELY SAY.
WITH THAT LANGUAGE, IT'S NOT
GOING TO WORK.
I THINK WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
TRYING TO GET AT, AND HE USED
IMPRECISE LANGUAGE, HE'S TALKING
ABOUT A DATABASE FOR WHAT HE
CALLS THE CRAZY GUYS.
A DATABASE WHERE IF SCHOOL
OFFICIALS AND POLICE OFFICERS
NOTICE SOMETHING WRONG, IT'S NOT
ABOUT DUE PROCESS.
ACTUALLY THAT IS THE DUE
PROCESS.
THEY SAY THIS PERSON IS A
THREAT.
HE HASN'T VIOLATED ANY LAWS YET.
THERE NEEDS TO BE A DATABASE FOR
THAT.
WHERE THAT PERSON GOES AND YOU
FIGURED OUT LATER.
HAD THAT POINT, THERE IS NO GUN.
IT'S IN A CIVIL COURT, SO THERE
IS A LOW BAR.
YOU CAN GET A JUDGE, DO A COURT
ORDER.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT HE'S GETTING
AT.
I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK THAT IS A SMART MOVE
BECAUSE I THINK IT MAKES SENSE.
ALONG WITH HARDENING SOFT
TARGETS IN DEALING WITH THE
MENTALLY ILL, THESE ARE ALL
PRACTICAL THINGS.
I THINK WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
DOING, WHICH IS VERY SMART, THEY
ARE PILING OTHER STUFF ON IT AND
THEY ARE SAYING THEY ARE LAUDING
HIM.
WHENEVER YOU GET PRAISE FROM A
LIBERAL, YOU SHOULD BE VERY
WORRIED.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT
THIS BEFORE.
IF THERE IS A REPUBLICAN WHO
MOVED TO THE METAL, YOU KNOW
IT'S GOING TO BE TRUMP BECAUSE
HE IS A POPULIST.
WHEN A POPULIST HERE'S SOMEBODY
SAYING DON'T TAKE AWAY MY GUNS,
THEY WILL SAND WITH YOU AND THEN
OF SOMEBODY ELSE'S GET THOSE
GUNS AWAY FROM THOSE GROUPS, HE
WILL STAND WITH YOU.
A POPULIST IS WITH THE POPULAR
OPINION.
IF THE POPULATION HAS TWO
DIFFERENT OPINIONS, HE WILL SAY
YES TO BOTH OF THEM.
>> Dana: I THINK WHAT IS
HAPPENING IS THERE IS A
CONVERSATION HAPPENING IN
WASHINGTON, AND THAT
CONVERSATION MIGHT NOT LEAD TO
LEGISLATION BUT THERE IS
MOVEMENT IN THE STATE.
FOR EXAMPLE, RICK SCOTT,
GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA, THEY PASSED
A LAW TO INCREASE THE AGE IN
TERMS OF PURCHASE.
HE'S GOING TO DEDICATE MONEY TO
HARDEN THE SCHOOLS.
THAT'S A HUGE COMMITMENT WHEN
YOU CAN SPEND IT ON A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS.
>> Jesse: IT IS AN ENORMOUS
COMMITMENT HER HE'S FEELING THE
HEAT DOWN AFFORDED.
I GET NERVOUS WHEN CRYING CHALK
ENDORSES SOMETHING.
MAKES ME RUN AND THE OTHER
DIRECTION.
THE PRESIDENT, USING IMPRECISELY
WHICH, AS YOU WOULD SAY, IT'S A
GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER.
IF SOMEBODY HASN'T COMMITTED A
CRIME OR HASN'T BEEN
INVOLUNTARILY COMMITTED TO A
MENTAL INSTITUTION BUT IS
KILLING ANIMALS AND ACTING CRAZY
AND BEATING UP HIS MOTHER AND IS
A MESS, LIKE THE KID IN FLORIDA.
YOU GO TO A JUDGE AND IT'S DUE
PROCESS AND THEY SAY IT'S TO
PREVENT HIM FROM TAKING A WEAPON
OR.
RUBIO SUPPORTS THIS.
THESE COPS WERE DEALING WITH
THIS VIOLENT, RIDICULOUS PERSON
CAUSING MAYHEM AND THEY WEREN'T
TREATING HIM LIKE A CRIMINAL.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO TREAT AN
18-YEAR-OLD HIGH SCHOOL KID LIKE
A CRIMINAL AND STOP SUSPENDING
HIM AND PUTTING HIM IN TIMEOUT
AND MAY BE    MAKE HIM PAY THE P
AND MAY BE    MAKE HIM PAY THE I
AND MAY BE    MAKE HIM PAY THE E
AND MAY BE    MAKE HIM PAY THE .
BACKGROUND CHECKS I CAN AGREE
WITH.
IT'S COMMON SENSE.
SHARING INFORMATION.
WHETHER YOU ARE SUSPENDED FOR
VIOLENCE, WHETHER IT'S A CRISIS
AT YOUR HOUSE AND YOU BEEN
CALLED -- THE POLICE 55 TIMES OR
WHATEVER.
PUT IT IN A SYSTEM AND MAKE SURE
EVERYONE HAS ACCESS.
RAISING THE AGE LIMIT, I AM
STILL WISHY-WASHY.
YOU DON'T WANT AN 18-YEAR-OLD
PERSON THEY GET TO GET A GUN BUT
AT THE SAME TIME, AND AR, BUT
THAT WOULDN'T HAVE PREVENTED
MOST OF THEM ARE PEOPLE ABOVE
18.
IF YOU ARE A HUNTER, IF YOU LIKE
SPORTS SHOOTING AND YOU ARE IN
OUR RURAL STATE, WHY DENY THEM
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
I DON'T GET THAT.
>> Dana: IS THERE SOMETHING
THE DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING THEY
THINK THAT IT'S AN ISSUE THAT
IT'S BUT FOR LAW SAY WHEN MIGHT
BE ABLE TO PASS IT?
>> Juan: TO THE CONTRARY.
THE POLITICS OF GUN CONTROL IN
THE COUNTRY ARE PRETTY CLEAR
WHICH IS ITS MOST AMERICANS WHO
FAVOR, AS JESSE JUST SAID,
UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND CHECKS,
CLOSING GUN SHOW LOOPHOLES,
GOING AFTER ASSAULT WEAPONS.
IT IS GUN OWNERS AND NONGUN
OWNERS.
>> Dana: EYES DIDN'T SAY GOING
AFTER ASSAULT WEAPONS.
>> Juan: I AM SAYING THAT.
MOST AMERICANS FAVORED DOING
AWAY WITH ASSAULT WEAPONS.
GUN OWNERS ARE SINGLE BOAT TYPE
PEOPLE.
THEY WILL VOTE ON THE SINGLE
ISSUE, GUNS.
PEOPLE WHO FAVOR OF GUN CONTROL
ARE NOT SINGLE ISSUE VOTERS AND
THEREFORE THEIR OPPOSITION IS
DILUTING.
IN THIS MOMENT, THE YOUNG PEOPLE
IN FLORIDA WE LEADING THE WAY,
YOU'RE SEEING A SHIFT IN
OPINION.
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER OR NOT
THE SHIFT IS ON THE RIGHT.
I THINK THAT'S WHY PRETTY MUCH
LIKE GREG SAID, SENATOR BEN
SASSE HAVE BEN SASSE OF NEBRASKA
SAID THE PRESIDENT IS REFLECTING
THE LAST PERSON TO TALK TO HIM.
YOUR PEOPLE LIKE BREITBART
SAYING IT IS TRUMP'S GUN GRAB.
PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT REACTING
REACTING AS IF WHAT IS TRUMP
DOING.
PEOPLE IN THE LAUGHTER SAYING
LET HIM DO WHAT HE WANTS TO DO
BUT HE HAS A FIGHT AMONG PEOPLE
WHO SUPPORTED HIM IN 2016.
EVEN WITH THE PLANS HE HAS PUT
FORWARD, CAN I GET 60 VOTES IN
THE SENATE WITHOUT STRONG
REPUBLICAN SUPPORT?
CAN I GET 218 IN THE HOUSE?
>> Dana: THAT'S WHY I SAID
MAYBE -- I'M NOT SAYING
LEGISLATION CAN'T PASS BUT IT'S
UNLIKELY I THINK THAT IT WOULD
PASS THIS YEAR.
IN THE STATES, YOU ARE SEEING
THINGS.
ALSO THE MARKET IS SORT OF
DEALING WITH SOME OF THIS.
YESTERDAY WALMART SAID IT WOULD
NO LONGER, IT WAS RAISING THE
AGE LIMIT TO 21 FOR ITS STORES.
ALSO KROGER SAID THE SAME THING.
I DIDN'T KNOW THEY SOLD GUNS
THERE.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A GROCERY
STORE.
>> Kimberly: SOMETHING YOU
SAID I FOUND TO BE VERY
INTERESTING WHICH WAS MAYBE
THERE IS A BIT OF A SHIFT.
PERHAPS MAYBE IN SOME SENSE ON
THE RIGHT AND CERTAINLY WE ARE
SEEING A LITTLE BIT WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
HE IS TRYING TO BE VERY
OPEN-MINDED.
LISTEN TO BOTH SIDES.
EVALUATE THE SITUATION.
PERHAPS WITH THE YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT WERE SO PERSONALLY AND
TRAGICALLY AFFECTED, IT'S
CHANGED A LITTLE BIT OF THE
TONE.
THE WILLINGNESS TO LISTEN, TRY
TO DO SOMETHING BETTER.
IT'S NOT POLITICIANS, ALTHOUGH
SOME OF THEM WERE MOTIVATED IN
CERTAIN WAYS BY DIFFERENT
PARENTAL IDEOLOGY AND WHATNOT.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK PEOPLE ARE
LISTENING TO.
NOT THIS CONGRESS MENTOR THIS
REPUBLICAN OR THIS DEMOCRAT,
IT'S PEOPLE WHO WERE THERE,
EXPERIENCE LOSS AND TRAGEDY AND
SUFFERING.
THEY ARE BEING REAL IN TERMS OF
HOW THEY EXPERIENCED IT.
GENUINE IN TERMS OF WANTING TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
EVEN THE FIRST LADY COMMENTED ON
IT.
THE CHILDREN ARE USING THEIR
VOICE AND THEY ARE TRYING TO GET
IT OUT THERE TO DO SOMETHING SO
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN TO
SOMEBODY ELSE.
THAT'S WHY I THINK YOU SEE THE
PRESIDENT MAKING THE SHIFT.
>> Dana: YESTERDAY MICHAEL
HAMMAN, LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL FOR
GUN OWNERS OF AMERICA.
"WHAT WE BELIEVE HE IS GONE FROM
THE SECOND AMENDMENT'S BEST
FRIEND TO THE GUN GRABBER IN
CHIEF."
>> Greg: BILLS COULD BOTH BE
TRUE.
HE HAD VERY CENTER LIBERAL
BELIEFS FOR A LONG TIME ABOUT
GUNS.
THEN HE KNEW WHO WE HAD TO
PLEASE.
THIS IS WHAT IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU
GET A POPULIST.
FOR BETTER OR WORSE, PEOPLE ARE
VERY PRO-POPULIST BUT YOU NEVER
KNOW WHAT THE NEXT DAY IS GOING
TO BRING BECAUSE IT'S BASED ON
POPULAR OPINION.
HERE'S MY CONCERN.
WHAT WORRIES ME AS WE ARE GOING
TO END UP PUNISHING LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS.
NOT JUST IN GUNS BUT OTHER
ARENAS.
IF YOU DECIDE TO RIG THE SYSTEM
TO MAKE IT HARDER FOR LEGAL,
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS TO GET
GUNS.
YOU ARE NOT TARGETING THE ACTUAL
TROUBLES.
TARGET THE PEOPLE WHO NEED TO BE
TARGETED.
HE PUT THEM IN A DATABASE.
I'M SEEING THIS HAPPEN WITH
OPIOIDS.
DONALD TRUMP TALKING ABOUT, THE
GOVERNMENT SUING PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES.
THEY ARE TARGETING LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS BECAUSE OF A TINY
PERCENTAGE OF ABUSE.
GOING TO GO AFTER THE COMPANIES
THAT CREATE THE DRUGS AND
THEY'RE GOING TO MAKE IT HARDER
FOR CANCER PATIENTS, PEOPLE WITH
ILLNESSES TO MAKE      GET OPIOI
ILLNESSES TO MAKE      GET OPIOS
ILLNESSES TO MAKE      GET OPIOB
ILLNESSES TO MAKE      GET OPIOC
ILLNESSES TO MAKE      GET OPIOU
ILLNESSES TO MAKE      GET OPIOE
THERE IS ABUSE.
THERE'S A SMALL AMOUNT OF ABUSE.
IT'S A PARALLEL ARGUMENT TO
GUNS.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE GUNS ARE
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS.
THE PEOPLE THAT USE LEGAL
MEDICATIONS ARE LAW-ABIDING
PEOPLE WITH CANCER, WITH PAIN
DISORDERS.
WE ARE PUNISHING PEOPLE BY
CREATING, GOING AFTER THE SYSTEM
ABUSERS.
>> Juan: I THINK WE ARE GOING
AFTER THE IDEA THAT THERE'S BEEN
SUCH A PROLIFERATION OF GUNS IN
AMERICAN SOCIETY.
>> Greg: THERE HAVE BEEN
MEDICATIONS.
DO YOU SEE MY POINT?
THERE IS A PROLIFERATE OF
MEDICATION.
>> Juan: IN TERMS OF HEALING
YOUR BODY.
>> Greg: A GUN HAS A PURPOSE.
>> Juan: YOU SAY SELF-DEFENSE
FOR EXAMPLE.
I AM SAYING THAT IF PEOPLE ARE
ABLE TO DEFEND THEMSELVES, AND
WE HAVE A PROBLEM WITH MASS
MURDERERS IN SOCIETY.
MY ARGUMENT IS YOU GET THE GUN
OWNERS OF AMERICA, TO THE RIGHT
OF THE NRA.
THEY ARE MORE RADICAL THAN THE
NRA AND GUNS.
THEY ARE NOW PUTTING PRESSURE ON
THE NRA.
CAN THE NRA SAY YOU KNOW WHAT,
MR. PRESIDENT.
APPARENTLY THAT'S WHAT HE SAID
THEY TOLD HIM IN THE LUNCH.
WE ARE WILLING TO DO SOMETHING.
WE WANT TO MAKE OUR NATION
SAFER, OUR CHILDREN SAFER, AS